merci d'être là j'aimerais parler avec
vous d'environnement car vous comme moi
depuis qu'on est petit on nous nous
envoient beaucoup de messages sur les
petits gestes du quotidien pour pour
protéger la planète acheté des lampes à
économie d'énergie couper l'eau du
robinet quand on se brosse les dents
c'est très bien mais sincèrement je suis
pas entièrement convaincu évidemment ce
sont des bons conseils il faut les
suivre mais je suis pas je suis pas
convaincu que ça avec les 50 litres
d'eau que j'économise parents en
brossant les dents que je vais vraiment
avoir un impact sur la planète
et puis c'est un autre effet ces
conseils là il nous laisse croire que
nous en tant que citoyens sont les
seules choses qu'on peut faire pour
avoir une maîtrise de notre consommation
et notre impact
et puis pendant ce temps là les grands
de ce monde sont des grandes réunions
pour gérer les problèmes c'est eux qui
s'en occupe la dernière fois que tout le
monde s'est réuni c'était en décembre
dernier à paris pour la coop 21 vous
avez dû en entendre en entendent parler
tous les gouvernements étaient étaient
réunis parce qu'en effet la planète va
va très mal
il ya pas mal de problèmes la pollution
la pollution augmente
je passe mes slide en même temps la
pollution augmente les océans meurent
les forêts souffre
et les glaciers fondent bref ça va ça va
pas fort du tout et tout ça c'est en
grande partie à cause des activités
humaines
l'atmosphère se réchauffe à cause de la
concentration des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre dans l'atmosphère et on
peut se demander jusqu'où la température
peut monter et les scientifiques
s'accordent à dire que sur une hausse
qui va être limitée à 2 degrés
globalement les équilibres du climat
vont pas vraiment évolué le problème
c'est que malgré toutes ces grandes
réunions internationales comme la coop
21 les émissions de gaz à effet serre
continuent d'augmenter très vite
et alors là on doit se préparer à des
gros problèmes
en effet l'accélération de la fonte des
glaces par exemple elle peut faire
augmenter le niveau des océans de
plusieurs mètres le dégel des glaciers
peut libérer des gigantesques quantités
de méthane qui est un gaz à effet de
serre très polluants qui est stockée
pour l'instant dans ce qu'on appelle le
permafrost en russie en sibérie en
arctique chaque année on doit se
préparer à affronter d'un côté de la
planète des inondations et des tempêtes
alors que de l'autre on en affrontera
des sécheresses et des canicules qu'on
n'a jamais vue jusqu'ici
et du coup on peut se demander si les
scénarios de science fiction qu'on voit
dans les films
est ce que l'on doit s'y préparer un
jour à les affronter pour de vrai bref
tout ça pour dire qui est un d'allumer
en sortant du salon et faire pipi sous
la douche pour économiser une chasse
d'eau c'est vraiment très bien mais je
suis sûr qu'on peut aller on peut aller
un peu plus loin
la jeunesse ne doit pas attendre qu'on
agisse pour elle vraiment vraiment on
peut le faire vous pouvez le faire
chacun d'entre vous depuis tout petit je
suis très sensible à la planète les
forêts les animaux et c'est vrai que
après des études finalement assez
généraliste j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir
m'engager dans une association écolo
dont le projet c'était justement la
protection de la nature
la diminution de l'impact
comme sur sur la planète et notamment
l'accès à l'énergie pour tous et l'accès
à l'énergie pour tous pour moi c'est une
problématique assez importante parce
qu'il ya un paradoxe amusant amusant
façon de parler
malgré tout les quantités d'énergie
qu'on produit chaque jour dans le monde
qui sont absolument colossal ya quand
même un milliard et demi de personnes
qui ont pas accès à l'électricité
j'étais gêné par cette situation et je
me posais la question quand est ce que
des citoyens des chercheurs des
associations vont développer eux-mêmes
leurs propres solutions pour fournir
l'accès à une énergie propre au plus
grand nombre
alors il ya cinq ans de cela alors que
j'avais un emploi j'étais bien installé
dans ma vie j'ai décidé de tout quitter
j'ai quitté mon nom cdi pour créer ma
propre ong qui s'appelle africa express
l'objectif de cette association est
justement d'aller à la rencontre de ces
hommes et de ces femmes qui font des
projets qui développe des idées et qui
arrive à améliorer la vie de leurs
communautés en leur fournissant de
l'accès à une énergie propre et ça
spécialement dans les pays africains
alors pourquoi l'afrique est bien à
cause de cette de cette photo satellite
qui montrent en fait la photo de la
planète la nuit et on voit que les
éclairages montre les grandes villes du
monde et puis les gros point d'activité
économique est ce qui choque un peu sur
7 sur cette photo satellite c'est que
l'afrique elle est pratiquement
pratiquement plongée dans le noir
et en effet il ya 650 millions de
personnes en afrique qui n'ont pas accès
à l'électricité ou 1 ou à l'énergie de
manière plus globale
donc j'ai parti sur le terrain pendant
un an pour rencontrer des gens qui
vraiment développe des projets ce voyage
a duré un an et il a vraiment changé ma
vie alors j'aimerais vous présenter tous
les entrepreneurs les garçons et les
filles qui
qui développe des projets que j'ai
rencontré et qui ont bouleversé ma
vision du monde
mais bon j'ai pas assez de temps et puis
vous avez tous pleins d'autres choses à
faire il ya des supers speaker après
qu'ils ont des choses exceptionnelles a
raconté aussi donc on a décidé de se
limiter à trois personnes mais ces trois
garçons et filles ont développé chacun
dans leur genre et puis dans leur pays
une activité qui permet un de développer
un business c'est à dire un modèle
économique
ils arrivent à se payer engager des gens
et puis à faire une activité économique
durable de de fournir l'accès à une
énergie propre et 3 de diminuer leur
impact sur la planète donc boulot energy
planet c'est quand même pas mal
et regardez saïd par exemple qui est un
jeune entrepreneur kényan qui a une idée
très simple il est parti d'un constat
qui est un vrai paradoxe de l'afrique
subsaharienne qui est le suivant en
afrique tout le monde a un portable un
téléphone portable vraiment 100 % des
gens sont en sont équipés seulement le
problème c'est que le réseau électrique
ne suis pas du tout et partout on se
trouve sur le continent de la grande
ville au coin le plus reculé dans les
montagnes dans le désert dans la forêt
on capte le téléphone mais par contre il
faut faire jusqu'à 15 km à pied parfois
pour aller recharger son téléphone
je sais pas si vous vous rendez compte
mais c'est comme si vous tous les matins
vous avez jusqu'à mairie des lilas à
pied pour recharger votre téléphone ou
pas c'est difficile à vivre et pourtant
c'est une vraie réalité est alors saïdi
l'a eu
il a une idée simple il a été assez
direct il n'a pas attendu que que
l'opérateur national d'électricité tire
le câble électrique jusqu'à lui il n'a
pas signé une pétition en ligne pour
réclamer qu'on amène électricité il a
été assez direct il a acheté il a acheté
un panneau solaire grâce à grâce à un
microcrédit
il a bricolé une plaque avec une
cinquantaine de prises électriques et il
a créé un service de rechargement de
mobiles dans son village y personnes
comme il est mais du coup dans son
village ça permet à tout le monde pour
quelques centimes de venir recharger son
téléphone
il a lancé sa propre activité il est
devenu entrepreneur il a une vraie
utilité sociale pour sa communauté
la jeunesse ne doit pas attendre qu'on
agisse pour elle développé sa propre
activité qu'elle soit lucrative ou
associative c'est vraiment un bon moyen
de s'engager
tenez regardez le panneau solaire de
saïd et puis regardez fostat qui vit au
nord de la tanzanie
avant elle était professeur des écoles
et puis elle a écouté savoir et elle a
décidé de se reconvertir
elle fabrique maintenant des foyers de
puissants améliorer ce sont des four en
terre cuite qui permettent de diviser
par deux la consommation de charbon de
bois par rapport aux feux traditionnels
qu'on peut qu'on peut faire elle
accompagnée par une ong européenne et
elle commercialise ses fours sur les
marchés pour un tarif d'environ 20
dollars ce qui reste quand même assez
accessible pour pour tous les foyers
d'autant plus qu'ils permettent à chaque
utilisateur d'économiser à peu près 50
dollars par an de charbon de bois c'est
autant d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre qu'on n'aimait pas dans
l'atmosphère et c'est autant de pression
en moins sur les forêts environnantes
elle a commencé seul et aujourd'hui elle
emploie une dizaine de salariés comme
sur énormément de projets que j'ai eu
l'occasion de voir en afrique le rôle
des femmes est très important souvent
elles sont garantes de la bonne gestion
des fonds et du bon développement du
projet on a un cas similaire avec avec
henriette henriette est les béninoises
et elle gère une communauté agricole
entièrement entièrement dirigée par des
femmes
il s'agit de réaliser la première
transformation des fruits ou des
céréales qui sont produits sur sur ce
sur ce domaine sur ce territoire
c'est moudre la farine
du blé ou du maïs pressez le jus des
fruits etc
comme il est difficile et coûteux de se
procurer de l'essence dans cette région
pour faire fonctionner ces presses et
puis ces moulins elles ont décidé toutes
ces femmes de d'adapter leur machine
pour qu'elle fonctionne avec de l'huile
de graines de jatropha comme carburant
alors le jatropha
c'est une plante oléagineuse locale qui
donne une île très très riches et en
utilisant ce carburant au lieu de
l'essence qui provient en général du
nigeria qui est le pays voisin
elle fait vivre une rue une filière
locale composée d'agriculteurs et de
transformateurs des villages voisins et
elle évite elle aussi l'émission de gaz
à effet de serre liées à la consommation
de carburant elle a décidé elle aussi de
lancer sa propre entreprise
et ça marche très très bien vous le
voyez ce sont aussi bien saïd
qu'henriette que fos tarn des personnes
assez ordinaire comme vous et moi mais
elles ont eu une idée
elles ont décidé de la suivre et elles
accomplissent de grandes choses par la
force de leur volonté
elles sont devenus entrepreneurs elle
joue un rôle important au sein de leur
communauté
et elle développe un business social
elle s'engage vraiment pour la planète
alors pourquoi pas nous au niveau
personnel c'est vrai que pour moi
annoncé à ma famille et mes amis à
quelques années que j'allais tout
quitter pour partir en afrique
tout le monde m'a pris pour un fou mais
au final c'est vraiment la meilleure
décision que j'ai prise
j'ai pu rencontrer des personnes
incroyables analyser leurs projets
parfois les aider pour pour améliorer
certains trucs et puis surtout j'ai
écrit un livre scientifique sur le sujet
que j'ai mis à disposition gratuitement
sur internet
et depuis il a été lu plus de dix mille
fois par des entrepreneurs d'afrique et
d'ailleurs qui ont pu s'en servir comme
source pour développer leurs propres
projets aujourd'hui à titre personnel
vraiment je poursuis mon engagement en
sensibilisant les jeunes au
développement durable notamment dans les
festivals de musique
tout ça pour vous dire que la jeunesse
ne doit pas attendre qu'on agisse pour
elle comme chacun d'entre nous vous avez
le potentiel pour changer le monde
alors maintenant faite le